what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
[Music]
the following episode is part of the
off-the-chain automation series
sponsored by iota the goal of this
special series is to explore the
intersection of distributed ledger
technology and automation specifically
around digital currencies digital
wallets and machine-to-machine
transactions my core belief is that
every stock bond currency and commodity
will eventually be digitized and
distributed ledger technology will
empower the full potential of automation
to be realized
iota is the sponsor of the automation
series their mission is to support the
research and development of new
distributed ledger technologies
including IOT tangle the iota foundation
encourages the education and adoption of
distributed ledger technologies through
the creation of ecosystems and the
standardization of these new protocols
you can find out more about the
automation series and iota in the show
notes
Anthony pomp Liana is a partner at
Morton Creek Digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only all right
guys
bang-bang I'm here with Tom I'm super
excited to do this you are mr. research
in the crypto world
shout out to my Delphi guys the -
they're like the Tom Lee of the future
thank you so much for taking time - what
kind of record thanks good to be here
absolutely your background first so that
we know your perspective for the
conversation or fun shot so I've been a
research analyst since 1993 so for the
last 27 years studied companies and
markets for the first half of that I was
a technology analyst I covered the
wireless industry
people take for granted today that
Wireless is everywhere but in 1993 there
were 34 million cell phones today
there's four and a half billion and in
the early 90s everybody thought cell
phones were gonna be yuppie toys and you
know I think that I was very lucky
because I was in my 20s covering an
industry that was not really considered
legitimate but growing very quickly and
I started to get recognized in this
thing called institutional investor
which is this research poll that rates
analysts and I became ranked very
quickly I was one of the youngest people
to become high ranked and I think the
reason I was kind of recognized by our
clients was I had a different
perspective of how technology would be
used in Wireless because to me it was a
quantum leap in utility I think a lot of
people thought Wireless was going to be
a way to protect traditional long
distance and local telephony and you
know so I think that perspective really
helped and then in the early 2000s I
switched from wireless to doing
bankruptcy research and I wrote a report
called the chapter after chapter 11 I
talked about how companies that were in
bankruptcy were actually better
investments than people realized because
once it come he goes into bankruptcy it
becomes a legitimate and orphaned and so
as it emerges no one wants to touch it
again so it turns out those are great
stocks and JP Morgan really likes sort
of what we were doing there and then
asked me
no7 to become their chief equity
strategist and write about markets
broadly and so I've been doing that for
the last 12 years and then four years
ago we started fun strat with my partner
John Bay and it's kind of the same thing
you know we just focus on institutional
investors and we give them really
detailed highly you know researched
research on markets and views and that's
what we do how going from technology to
equities to crypto because you guys have
started to cover
very quickly become known for it how did
you person come across Bitcoin or any of
the watching nanotechnology um yeah you
know Bitcoin was on the periphery well
as at JPMorgan our FX strategist at the
time was writing about it and in 2014
you know he even posited the idea that
someday it might be in a currency basket
and so I think as a macro team we used
to talk about it but at the time it was
essentially viewed as somewhat tainted
you know in large organizations because
seen as you know used for buying drugs
and of waiting taxes and so I I didn't
pay too much attention but then when we
started fun strat we were a little more
free to kind of just revisit topics and
a few years ago we just said let's
revisit this whole idea of Bitcoin
because at the time it it looks like it
survived and we wrote a piece and you
know it's just the idea that look even
if you were just to make the assumption
that this was just gonna be digital gold
it's probably a huge risk reward and so
I was her first sort of thought and and
working to Bitcoin and that was mid-2017
right yeah you know and then what the
name funds so it's just a concatenation
fundamental strategy and that's what we
are we're bottoms up firm that look at
Bottoms Up data but we developed that
into a macro strategy view I think it's
different our clients tend of us is
differentiated because strategy work
tends to be high level you know based on
macroeconomic inputs to derive views you
know our view is the idea that not only
are top-down important which it is
important but bottoms up really helps to
confirm or identify variants so we do
fun strap make sense and then just kind
of from a researcher standpoint
how do you view Bitcoin and crypto in
the broader macro strategy right what
are you seeing there what's kind of the
research legend today um you know I
think that if we looked at how funds
institutional hedge funds and individual
portfolio managers have survived the
past 20 years they've really adopted and
understood the importance of network
value companies you know so companies
where network effects really come into
play it's like your former company
Facebook all the social media companies
but it's also true that these sort of
platform entities and growth are asset
like businesses and and that's really
what we've seen outperforming in the in
the macro world crypto really fits well
into that you know bitcoin is really the
ultimate network value asset it's
exactly how the dollar is right the
dollar is as strong and as well-funded
as is even people argue it's because the
military I think it's just because it's
really widely used so I think over time
as bitcoins
adoption grows I think it's still a very
small number of active users and as it's
you know volatility improves I think it
becomes a true asset class but you know
it's it's we're still years away from
that for sure and one of the trends I
want to spend some time talking about is
the intersection of automation and
cryptocurrency or additional tokens
we're doing this automation series and
so what I'm really thinking through is
anytime you get multiple macro trends
that either intersect or kind of combine
it is usually a point of great value
creation right
and so maybe share a little bit about
what you're seeing from public markets
and outside of the door just on the
automation front and talk about that a
little bit and then we'll get into kind
of the intersection with digital on
space yeah I think automation is really
a mega trend like I think it's a trend
that's bigger than a lot of industrial
revolutions and what do you think that
well I think that there's two things two
really unique things happening in the
today that at this moment is creating
you know the big window for automation
one is cellular technology and
penetration and the speed of networks is
fast enough now to really enable
effective machine to meet machine
communications you know it was funny
because in the late 90s we used to call
it telematics you know the idea that oh
well when you have mobile cars can talk
to each other or devices and you know
the handshakes took too long it was easy
to intercept the signal you couldn't
authenticate if it was a genuine
communication so it was too early today
with 5g machines can now speak and
handshake and authenticate information
that gets lost today but I think the
second really important thing and I
don't think people fully appreciate this
but for the first time in 50 years the
world is running out of Labor so from
1974 to 2018 the primates workforce
globally grew faster than the total
population and it resulted in that 50
year period 611 million excess growth on
a 7 billion global population which
works out to 27 percentage points more
workers available for every unit of
output so you know for the last 50 years
you didn't have to worry about being
acid heavy or necessary robots because
there was so much cheap labor somewhere
where we've now completely flipped so in
the next 10 years the world is gonna be
short 80 million workers so automation
and IOT is going to be born out of
necessity so it's not the Terminator
scenario it's more that we're just gonna
have a shortage of workers yet what I
think of automation you know there's
definitely the Domesday of Hayward
displace much workers like life's over
you know humans are gonna be replaced by
all these machines and for me it's like
heaven we have heard this before right
where there's been so many other
destructive technologies that it was
gonna put all the humans out of work and
actually what it did was it got us out
of work that a lot who and it liked or
it wasn't very good use of our time and
it freed us up to go do other things to
create
to build things except yeah it's
actually the the betterment angle is
really the important thing I think a
really similar example is how frozen
food disrupted farming okay so you know
in the 1930s 36% of the US labor force
with farmers and if you said in 1936 by
1959 only five percent of the population
would be farmers some economists would
say oh you're gonna have a massive
collapse of the US economy because
you're gonna put 29 percent of the
workforce out of work
well the disruption was because of
flash-frozen flash-frozen reduce the
spoilage you know 40 percent of fresh
food spoiled it transformed the grocery
store used to grocery stores used to
almost always be fresh now it became
frozen and it caused a massive deflation
in food wallet you know food used to be
20% of the wallet and it's now less than
10 but that drop in twenty to ten
created discretionary money to go
traveling for people to buy TVs so it
actually created a lot of leisure time
and productivity in America and of
course you know the u.s. boomed so you
know taking farmers and putting them
into factories was really productive
absolutely
as this happens GM a sense of our
mission becomes just more pervasive
through various aspects of work today
where do the humans go next likely do
you know what some of those kind of more
frontier markets look like or do we
still need some more time to figure that
out it's a great question I think you
know you know McKinsey had a great study
a few years ago where they said you know
what jobs are the least likely to be
automated and it's things where there's
judgement required so making you know
research decisions discoveries managing
people and robots I think that that's
gonna be source of employment I think
that the other possibility is that
people just have more leisure time and
look you know today leisure time isn't
valued because most people pursue it
with maybe you know not being productive
but
you know in 20 years what if everyone
has an extra 10 hours to to study the
world make scientific discoveries you
know make social observations do art I
think it could be quite beneficial
assist to society so I you know it's a
good question I don't know for sure and
yeah the other piece of it it I thought
I would joke you said that is like you
know the machines are gonna replace us
no I'm just gonna manage the machines
yeah that's kind of what we've seen in
factories right you know before we had
any sort of machinery it was just humans
doing the tasks then we got machines in
place and now we have people who manage
those machines and the people got freed
up when did other things and along your
lines of where judgment is required I
think of it as judgement and or
creativity right so so creativity is
kind of a form of judgment but if you
look at all of the things that have
popped up through social media content
and all these aspects could make it real
money doing this stuff right now and
could easily see a portion of the
population moving to more creative based
jobs which are just part of machines to
do or that those judgment based jobs
that I've described yeah and I I think
it would be really useful Society I mean
if you think about you know who we
really respected in past centuries it
was always artists writers you know
people making discoveries in the last 50
years the only people that really get
respected are people who make money so I
think the focus on money is you know I
think by nature in a world of automation
and productivity money will be less
important mm-hmm well and so it brings
me to maybe boo listen of podcast no our
two core thesis in this industry crypto
and the first is that Bitcoin as a store
of value is very interesting and it has
the potential to be one of the most
disruptive pieces of technology we'll
see in our lifetime and that thesis is
really driven by the idea that people
will trust an algorithm more than they
will trust other humans right you know
at the kind of score you see that other
aspects of your life in the financial
role I think it's gonna happen and a
store value asset with contracting
securities
a huge piece of that the second thesis
is every stock bond currency and
commodity will get digitized at some
point in the future and really that
thesis is built on the idea of that this
theme of automation where machines are
actually able to work with each other
talk to each other get things done when
you coordinate them together once you
have the units of value the literally
stocks bonds currencies your commodities
and the machines can now transact with
each other right and so that is a huge
kind of inflection point for automation
because you're actually digitizing the
the unit of value rather than just
having kind of the two participants in a
transaction to digital or machinery yeah
I agree and I think that you know sort
of a overlaying all that is that it's
gonna be a transformation of what is
accounts for money okay um well today
you know money is really defined as a
unit of account that a country would
issue right and in the past you could
have exchanged it for hard money for
gold today of course if your currency is
now just exchange for nothing
it's just backed by nothing yeah a
belief system and but when we think
about digital money like Bitcoin and
it's a really brilliant execution
because you know as you mention it it's
really putting trust onto the blockchain
instead of saying hey look trust me this
is a real dollar bill but over time
other things are quite valuable that we
don't call money so for instance a
reputation or authenticity is worth zero
today but we've seen how it's monetized
through sponsorships so I think things
like reputation or morality or you know
effectiveness are going to be forms of
monetization and that's really valuable
because that means people don't have to
worry about you know how many dollars
they make a month if they it's really
how much accumulated value do they have
that they get exchanged for other goods
and services and yes and even powering
robots you know you do want to make sure
we can sort of authentically cut off and
shut down a robot especially is if they
get smart absolutely
I think of this whole idea of
intersecting digital tokens money value
etc with the automated machines the
examples that I think through are
there's like a scale of automation right
or spectrum so you have full automation
or you have like semi autonomous or
things any see examples are you know
give that car it's gonna drive down the
road rather than stop have a human pull
out fiat currency out of their pocket
and hand it to another human who then
does some accounting right and gives you
change and you driving that car can
simply just drive over a sensor it
basically pays from the car a digital
asset to the you know the road or the
sensor all the accounting is automated
all of the transactions automated the
person never even has to slow down
they're just drunk right we kind of have
this with like an EZ Pass right so you
know if you kind of drive through it's
just got a little bit more friction than
this fully digital system are there
other examples where you guys have
thought about or come across in your
research where you think that there's
like very obvious intersections or
things that you get excited about and in
that well um
you so autos I think interestingly is
probably one of the most important and
obvious and and really a huge deal
become because it really blends the idea
of like what's money versus time to give
an example you know when the when the
government measures productivity its
measured in tenths of an hour's worked
so 10th of an hour worked gained is a
Productivity miracle okay a tenth of a
40-hour week is basically a tenth of 40
hours which is you know it's like 10
minutes so if you can cut out two
minutes out of someone's commute right
out of a 40-minute commute that is a
Productivity miracle and automation
whether it's like you said pass an easy
pass or you're charging on the road
instead of you know at at a charging
station or traffic is optimized
that's a Productivity miracle and that
would show up as like oh my gosh
having it productivity boom in fact you
know commute times the last 40 years
have increased in the Northeast so
people it takes longer for people to get
to work the same distance and so you
know you could extend how people commute
so I think you know what you've
described is the single most practical
use of automation but there's others I
mean I'd say financial transactions
broadly any time that you're exchanging
money is probably the best place to look
for automation to boom today if you look
at global financial industry share of
GDP so what they call value capture
according to the OECD it's six percent
of GDP so that means eight six that
means the average person spends three
and a half weeks a year paying for the
right to use the financial system so
you're spending a month of your salary
just to say oh I want to use this
monetary system so I think automation
and IOT really take away that friction
and it should be you know people should
spend one day of their salary a year to
use the financial system that's a huge
amount that's for twenty dollars
unlocked and another example way to
think that is you know today banks lend
and they're primarily in charge of
determine if you're a good credit they
make about a thousand dollars a year off
each customer Facebook and on social
media companies probably have a better
feel for you as a credit in fact a cell
phone company told me that one of the
best predictors of credit quality of
their customers who are on a IP
installment plans is what is how often
they let their phone battery died so
they found that the irresponsible
credits are the people that let a phone
battery died so it turns out social
media and all these companies can make
better lending decisions and that and
through their ability to enter the
banking system can really reduce the
value capture the financial industry
it's interesting you say that because
I've seen a couple of companies that
want to use phone data to actually
underwrite loans right so yeah very
similar stuff I want to go back to the
machine obscene transactions for a
second because you know as I thought
weren't more about this I try to draw
parallels to the world that exist today
right and so if you just think of when
you go to Starbucks or now even in New
York City in the subway
you can take your phone which is a
machine right and kind of just sit in
front of a sensor or another machine and
pay for things identical even as far as
to say that you can make the
extrapolation of the humans of our a
type of machine right we just have seen
images over na we see different energy
yeah we yeah we just
there's non-human machines in those
human machines right now but but our
face is now starting to act like a
wallet right by me but there's a fee of
the Amazon ghost stores right where you
look in the facial recognition knows who
you are they're able to link that to an
account walk off of the store you pick
up items and you walk out they charges
you right so your face acted as and you
know the equivalent of a wallet in that
case in all of this you know I've been
kind of thinking about it around the
periphery and you know when I originally
met the the guy said iota they were
telling me about this like wallet inside
of a car right I started to think we'll
be able to wallet in your phone right
that's a digital wall with digital
assets you can go pay for all these
things that you put with that phone in
front of something and then you have a
wallet inside of your car and your car
can basically pay for things you very
quickly get to a world where there's a
whole bunch of machines that you and I
interact with on a daily basis that
could be a wallet in the future or could
be a participant a transaction right you
know the sender or a receiver and so to
me it just it changes the way we think
about value and transactions and I don't
know where the line is like where is the
line of reasonable expectations of the
future versus you know 20 years ago
because we're not flying mmm now you
know yeah there is some line of like
what is possible and what's not let's
say the next 10 or 20 years where you
kind of feel you know it is likely
versus maybe some of this stuff is pipe
dream stuff and
what you doubt her yeah it's a it's a
great question and you know I and iota
is really doing some clever things
because you know they're not they're
capturing quite a lot of information
right so on on on a on an on a network
like that you not only are capturing
maybe the movement of money but really
they move the transfer of information
and and that information is generally
lost
I think machine-to-machine really is the
place where we're gonna see true network
effects take place and you know from
what's practical I think we know it's a
dream for advertisers to know for you to
exchange more information about yourself
so I think as a practical matter you
know one of the implications for this is
that a lot of things that we do today
could actually become free you know or
or companies might even pay us for just
walking around you know Facebook might
pay quality users money to be a
subscriber or someone who has social
impact could actually be paid and you
know is in terms of what's practical I
think wherever people feel like they
gain personal time that's gonna make a
difference so you know that's why I come
back to the commute I think commuting is
probably the biggest loss of time for
people today you know if someone spends
an hour commuting that's 2 hours a day
they're awake you know 12 hours it's a
huge percentage of their time that just
got lost and if you don't have to drive
yourself somewhere yeah right
you literally could just get into a
vehicle in your drive leg and be
productive whether you want to use it to
actually be productive or just entertain
yourself
that's exactly right hi yeah right I
mean like that's a pretty serious
inflection point in humanity's
productivity right the dam can do that
week hours yeah and that's an incredible
percentage of time and you know it can
be future of hey it's an extension area
living room or it could be a meeting
room or could be a social period of time
or you know there's a lot of ways that
could be transformed and that's
networked value um you know might be
interesting to see how sleep is
transformed to because you know we spend
eight hours sleeping and who knows maybe
our sleeping habits or you know the hive
mind of what happens in our sleep could
be useful information so I you know I
think there's a lot of things but I
think we all have to think about you
know how are 24 hours a day is
transformed mm-hmm
as you look further and further out into
where some of this stuff is going how
much of this is sequential right so
meaning we need X to happen first and
you know Y then Z versus it's all gonna
happen kind of simultaneously and you
just got push innovation for it you push
progress mall at the same time on these
different phones yeah in Wireless you
know cuz Wireless used to be where a lot
of R&D money was spent on you know new
technologies ways to joke is you know
the bleeding edge and it's tough to be a
bleeding edge company because the end
user doesn't care when it actually
happens and I think that if we look at
how technology gets adopted it never
gets adopted and all of a sudden it is
so I think we'll see companies really
pushing this on the edge even some
countries and then one day it's it's
pervasive what um any thoughts around
this whole neural link kernel the idea
of taking computers and I think about it
as the mobility of computing power has
gone from literally mainframes which had
no no no mobility and we went to it to
then you gotta bring it a little bit
closer a little bit closer than the
other you know PC then you got a phone
I'm just getting closer and closer to us
where it goes everywhere we go
but the ultimate end point is it's
literally embedded you know somewhere in
your body right now right start with a
brain but it could be anywhere pipedream
likely to happen timeline if you think
is gonna happen yeah um you know I mean
I'm not I wouldn't be surprised if you
know some of this outbound type of
things get implanted because you know I
think there's medical uses for that I
think the average person would get very
concerned about privacy and getting
hacked because you know imagine if
someone had a sensor and like they
didn't want someone to find out they're
like you know meeting their yeah they're
cheating on their wife or something you
know
and they sent it to the wrong channel so
I don't know it's interesting it's uh
it's gonna be an interesting world
because you know the the the younger
generations are really comfortable
sharing their information you know
there's many surveys that I've seen and
these are global surveys that show young
people trust technology companies way
more than they trust banks or
governments so they might be very
comfortable sharing this information and
you know maybe it'll just be the old
guard that sort of you know you know
puts a Faraday cage on their body just
so that they don't get personally hacked
for sure well and I think you know it's
kind of like this sci-fi becomes reality
at some point and so if you think
through I've been watching movies you
know for years where somebody hacks the
pacemaker right now its body and then if
you watch like black mirror episodes I
really think I've seen probably two or
three of those I'm not a huge watcher of
it but the tours are in flashes every
time like wow that's pretty crazy one I
remember basically your entire day is
recorded rest of your eyes are recording
like a video and then you can go home
and there's no woman yelling at a guy
like show me the video right and it's
literally every single thing he saw out
of his own two eyes
that's honey and he's got rewind it yeah
that's a little weird
and then the other is I kind of even go
as far as to say if you're gonna start
to implant a machine into your body and
we go back to the idea that the car
could be a wallet the phone could be a
wallet like is there a day we're
actually just the machine that is in
your body is the wallet right and so you
actually have all of the properties of a
digital wallet it's just embedded within
your body all this happening tomorrow
yeah you know 20 30 50 years from now it
could become very interesting you know I
I would say the majority of the
listeners are gonna think it's
preposterous I don't think it's that
crazy it ties into a very generalized
demographic observation I'd have which
is you know like when people think about
retirement social security is really a
proxy for how you measure that right you
know you get a Social Security payment
and at the time they established social
security and they actually began to
measure this with long-term disability
so in the 1960s they made it the average
period of time someone receives Social
Security would only be seven years so
you'd be work all your life and they get
this check for like seven years and then
you pass away with 62 yes and today
people can now expect to receive it for
as much as 40 years right so in just 50
years you've gone from receiving
something from seven years and it's a
10% of your life to something that's 40
years and 40% of your life I think in
the next 50 years we have to say how
much time are people gonna spend in
retirement I think it's gonna be 80% of
their life I think there's a possibility
people work for 10 years and by the time
their age 30 they're retired
so one of the things that is very
controversial I believe is this whole
answer to the ubi conversation so
University now is the idea that the
government will pay people some you know
some not only whatever it ends up being
and I've always said that I think you
can keep a lot of the same capitalistic
principles that we know today but where
people will get quote unquote
income a revenue is monetizing all the
data they create so if I'm sitting and
usually what earlier if I'm using a
internet service they could be paying me
to give them my personal data or just my
user data right what am I actually
looking at what adds it I said what did
i click on when it comes to personal
health data right so literally with my
blood pressure every day how many steps
did I take today right what did I eat
did my insulin go up do not like there's
plenty people that want that information
your DNA information right you can just
go down there's a lot of data that you
graduate every day we don't think of
that as valuable right in terms of I can
go sell it somewhere because there's no
physical marketplace you know show up
and be like hey download my phone to
give you money but I do think that
there's going to be these virtual
marketplaces that companies will build
where you will get paid for that data
and actually you probably can pay a lot
of them yeah that's right and you know
it in my implications creating two
classes people who are
sort of providing the information the
other people pay for it so you know
there'll be a narrow group of people
that actually could be quite highly paid
because their influence or their
archetype or their genetics are quite
attractive makes perfect sense I mean if
people don't believe it think about like
Dollar Shave Club I mean you know
shaving takes about five minutes or
something a day and and that's a
billion-dollar business you know we yeah
we have 24 hours a day to monetize yes
absolutely before we wrap up any at that
intersection of automation and crypto
any kind of big big guesses as to things
that are coming at maybe you are
thinking about well you know again I
think what our team's been working on is
looking for ideas where there are really
fast block change you know so I think
Bitcoin already occupies a vector that
is gonna be tough to challenge I mean
like you know after ten years you know
nothing is replaced Bitcoin and bitcoins
Bitcoin I think even close
nothing close exactly like when you and
we must television they don't even know
another word other than they don't even
think that there's other ass yeah in
terms of the conversation if you're just
watching you didn't know anything but
well there's Bitcoin and then there's
like all these other industries exactly
and and you know it's a myth when people
think Internet 2.0 companies came way
after Internet 1.0 you know Amazon and
its competitors like you know bookstore
to come or Facebook in MySpace or Yahoo
and google they were all founded within
12 months of each other you know it's so
big coin likely doesn't have a
competitor but you know IO T's I think a
huge huge use case for blockchains
and and you know sort of digital network
effects and you know we're looking at
projects like iota is one and there's
there's many others but look I think
it's a lot of opportunity in crypto but
bitcoin is Bitcoin
absolutely before I let you go ask every
guest about aliens believer or
non-believer I'm a believer
why well one I think that this is a huge
universe and I not surprised that there
would be other civilizations even
anybody whose biblical will know that
even in the Old Testament they were
nonhumans you know on earth but
secondly my brother we grew up in
Michigan he swears he's seen a UFO oh I
didn't so yeah just sit but I trust my
brother I don't think he was trying to
bamboozle me all right I thought you
were gonna tell me you met an alien oh
no it's gonna be a big if I have an
alien and who's telling me the future I
wouldn't tell you guys I just be trading
it for a 4i so we're not gonna see you
go in a storm area 51 with all know that
was me I really appreciate it I'm a huge
fan of the research that you guys are
doing so thanks so much thanks thanks
for you too good to come on and talk
about this stuff yeah well it's fun
let's do it again
hey everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way in
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain